what is this second lockdown going to
mean for business
well sophie it's an incredibly uh
difficult time for business this is a
real body blow so many firms have worked
very hard to become coveted safe they
have been resilient
uh through the first phase so this is
undoubtedly very tough
um but i do think that firms have shown
enormous innovation and resilience and
they can continue to do so
we need to do everything we can to
minimize the damage of the second
lockdown i think there are three things
we need to keep as much of the economy
open as we possibly can
and actually because more businesses are
covered safe now manufacturing
construction
should be able to stay open and the fact
that we have schools open
is really fundamental because people can
go to work we do need to protect jobs
and the enablers of the economy through
this
the fact we've got the job retention
scheme furlough continuing
is really really fundamental but the
final thing sophie and i think it's
almost the most important of all we need
to use the next four weeks to really
prepare
for what might come next and mass rapid
testing for business
could be a total game changer enabling
more of our economy to be open
and work uh safely and productively so
um i think businesses really rallying
around to try and make
uh this less damaging than the last
lockdown and to see us through
uh you mentioned that the photo scheme
the government's extended the furlough
scheme for
a month it doesn't need to be in place
for as long as these new restrictions
last for
it absolutely does and i think there is
one thing we need to get right now
is that economic support has felt too
often as though it's tail and charlie
it's business having to come and say now
we need this now we need that
instead of being part of the solution
right from the beginning
and we would really welcome
clarification from the government
right now that as long as these
restrictions are in place
the support will be in place because
businesses need to plan if that isn't
there then jobs will be lost
now yeah michael gove didn't quite
clarify that
earlier although he did a hint in that
direction and
is it possible that despite the support
that's in place
businesses that have you know struggled
to make it through the first lockdown
through all of the social restrictions
we've seen in the meantime
this could prove to be one step too far
for them and what could that mean in
terms of job losses
so i think we have to be really
realistic about this there are some ways
in which this lockdown
will be easier because i do think that
businesses are more ready and there's
more preparation schools are open but
resilience is very
low you have got businesses you've run
down cash even with loans we're running
to the
running towards the end of how effective
loans can be cash grants are going to be
now what we need more and more and i
think there is real
worry about certain sectors you know
aviation absolutely on its knees with
this
additional uh travel ban hospitality
there is a lot in place for hospitality
but supply chains going into hospitality
uh will be hugely affected so
i think the other thing that we really
need to be thinking more about
is how we train our young people to move
into the growth areas of the future
during this period
it gives us a breather people have a lot
of downtime
let's use it so that we can help the
economy uh to adjust and create jobs
um as well as as well as just protect
them yeah very difficult time for people
entering the job market as you say um i
just want to take a step back for a
minute because
you are stepping down as head of the cpi
after
a pretty extraordinary period at the
helm
at two elections three prime ministers
the eu referendum brexit and now covid
how do you think the governments that
you've seen have treated business in
that time
so sophie you're right i think when i
joined five years ago some people said
to me it was going to be quite a tame
time and it certainly hasn't proven
to be that um i think this has been a
challenging time for the relationship
between business and government
i think the uh the the challenge of the
uh redefining of the relationship with
the european union has been really hard
because so many businesses
valued a close relationship and and i've
been
trying to communicate uh that voice
throughout with
with evidence into the uh debate
but what i would say is that we have
seen i think
um some real change over the last six
months as we have worked together
business and government have been
working together
to create the job retention scheme to
create the support packages
and if we can build on that i think that
is something
nothing uh can be done i think coming
out of this without business and
government working together
whether it's on training whether it's on
uh whether it's on the recovery from
covid whether it is
climate change where i think business
has been absolutely
uh leading the charge uh so it's been
challenging
but i am i am very much of the view
that this could be a new chapter and
that we can build a
a partnership going forward that will
really make a difference
you mentioned brexit there and boris
johnson of course famously or
infamously once said f business when he
was asked to expand on that
at a conservative party hustings he said
i was referring to the very powerful
lobby groups who wanted to have a
particular type of exit from the
european union
um do you think that boris johnson is a
business friendly prime minister
i uh i think he is in his
uh in his bones but i think what we now
need to see
is that in action as i say i think that
the
uh the the importance of business
insight you know
the job creators the innovators they are
going to be british business
uh and unless we um have that kind of
insight
absolutely in the heart of number 10 and
it has been a disappointment to me
that there hasn't been a closer
relationship there the cbi speaks for
190 000 businesses
seven million employees across the uk
we've seen what we can do working with
government over the last six months of
this pandemic
let's take this in now to as i say the
climate change challenge the training
challenge
uh and um we um hope to be talking to
boris johnson
uh quite quite uh uh soon uh uh over the
next few days
uh directly it's our annual conference
and
this will be an opportunity i think for
the prime minister to make it
absolutely clear that he backs business
um because that is what this country
needs
that collaboration between government
and business to see us through
sounds like you were hesitating a little
bit before that answer so you
you're frankly a bit disappointed then
with the relationship that boris johnson
has had with business groups
i think it could be a lot better i
really do and
um i think this is a moment where
people really want to see different
parts of
our country pull together i mean i've
been uh proud to stand alongside francis
o'grady from the tuc on several
occasions over the last few years
people are sometimes surprised to see
that but what we've been able to do
is to say actually you need employees
you need business
you need all parts of government
devolved
regions and national to be pulling
together the public really want to see
that
and i think the prime minister has an
opportunity to stand for that
and part of that is going to be about
burying hatchets
you know brexit has been done we now
need the deal
that is really important it is over and
actually all the business now wants to
do is make a success of that
to move us forward and we have to do
that in partnership and i think the
british public want to see that